donald trump has instructed federal
agencies to cooperate with joe biden's
transition
team the closest meanwhile mr biden has
announced some key
cabinet picks as he puts together his
white house team so what do the
nominations tell us about the kind of
america we'll see
in 2021. joining me now is kelly hyman
who's a legal analyst and a strategist
for the democratic
party hello to you at kelly hyman and
let's start off
with donald trump and what it means can
we
call this a concession
well i would say it's about time i
wouldn't necessarily call it a
concession
um you know better late than never it's
unfortunate that it took trump so long
to do this usually there is a peaceful
transition
period trump has all the right to go
through the courts
and pursue his legal battles but
he's not going to win the american
people spoke and
they chose biden over 6 million people
chose biden over trump so now it's time
for us to move forward
and hopefully donald trump will concede
and help the transition team move
forward and that's what we want to move
forward with this country
so so it's a step forward but he's made
it very clear he's not
going without a fight and that fight
goes on
yes no absolutely um but you know
most of his challenges in the court the
cases have been dismissed
there has been no evidence of any type
of fraud
there's been nothing substantiated that
there was any type of
voter fraud and that people were so
concerned about
the election because trump months before
said oh there's going to be all this
voter fraud
and there's going to be all these
problems that really made sure that our
election
was safe and secure which it was and the
american people spoke
and they voted for biden and so now it's
time for a new administration
and we need to move forward we're just
looking at pictures
of president trump on the golf course
while he's been working on his swing
president-elect biden has been putting
together his
top team what does it look like and what
does it tell us
about the kind of administration he will
lead
it looks like what america is diversity
and also people that he picked have
experience
they have a lot of knowledge and there's
a lot of first especially for women
which is great um for latinos african
americans
it represents um what is great about
this country which is diversity
and all this talk about him picking
radical left extremists or
if biden gets elected it's going to turn
this country into socialism is a false
narrative
he is a moderate democrat and the people
that he picked are you know reflect that
and so his his picks are are wonderful
for our country and moving this country
uh forward
and helping the people on people here
are struggling i'm sure
in your country as well personally
professionally due to covet 19 and my
thoughts and prayers go out to them
and hopefully we can move something
forward to help these people that are
really struggling right now
struggling economically in particular
and
and he plans to nominate the former
federal reserve chair janet yellen to
the treasury
yes which is which is great um you know
um to have a woman there
um it's about time someone say and she
has the experience and knowledge
he's picking people with the experience
and knowledge
um to to to move this country forward
not people that are donors or
or you know don't have any experience so
it's very smart and strategic what he's
doing he's
he's picking people that have the
experience in the job
and have the knowledge to to help um
this country
move forward and also you know help with
our allies as well
another well-known known name john kerry
appointed climate envoy
yes no abs absolutely and he has great
knowledge and
and you know as you know trump has said
that you know climate change
um is a hoax which is another false
narrative there is really concern
about you know our climate and not only
for you know our country but for our
allies and out throughout
um this this world and so i think it's
really important that we
deal with that issue not only for us but
also for our
younger generations and our future
generations and we only have one planet
and i think it's great um that he chose
john kerry who served our country in the
u.s
is a war um hero and has expertise in
knowledge and would do
a great job very excited about that
president trump has pursued an america
first policy what about the appointment
the nominee for secretary of state and
what that
says about joe biden's vision for
america within the world
right well i i don't believe that that
trump was america first
um you know he did not uh put his
country first as you can see he's
reflecting the photos
you know he's he's out there golfing
while you know people
are dying every single day because of of
covet or struggling
personally professionally and you know
economically
i think that you know biden is is been
known to reach across the aisles
and and to work with people we can agree
to disagree and different philosophies
and i think his his his pick uh will you
know represent the diversity of our
country
and also um smooth out our allies
and work with other countries as well
i'm very excited about that
kelly hyman thank you very much indeed
thank you be safe stay healthy thank you